everyone great to be back at Gamescom
I'm Rex from Media Molecule this is
Michelle and we've also brought with us
at wah when we developed her away we
designed it completely around the Vita
but we started to wonder would it be
possible to bring tearaway to another
platform but porting its unique features
from the Vita seemed like an impossible
problem and then we realized it was an
impossible problem so we gave up sorry
we gave up on the idea of just porting
tearaway what we did is we looked at
another piece of hardware in the same
way that we looked at with the Vita what
exciting new things could we do with
this so we got together and we had a
game jam to really explore what we could
do to bring that same story of tearaway
to ps4 and look at how the controller
and the world would respond to each
other first off the light bar from the
controller would shine into the world
lighting it up as well as letting things
grow and you can see the effect it's
having here on our little paper theater
waking up the creatures growing all
these plants and welcome beards hmm nice
makeover the touchpad on the controller
would let us push down onto the surface
of the world as demonstrated by this
gopher and then will you release the
touchpad it would bounce back up again
and then throwing our messenger has
always been good at throwing objects
around demonstrated here by this
crash-test wendigo but we wondered could
we make more of a connection between the
messenger inside of the world and us
outside of it well by holding up
and then swiping those objects back into
the world can have some really dramatic
effects on the scenery we're taking the
messenger on the same overall journey is
on the Vita but reimagined for the big
screen with new environments and all of
these new methods of interacting with
them the last that we're showing now is
wind swiping on the touchpad sends a
powerful gust of wind into our paper
world in this case parting the waves so
that at work can carry on with her
delivery mission
and finally this wind allows us to
explore the now larger world not just on
foot but in the sky with the new paper
plane another way of helping the
messenger deliver the message in our big
screen adaptation of tearaway for
PlayStation 4